يعني انا مثلا لما جلست مع ميسي وزوجته
قالت انا بجي انا بجي الناس بس يعني
هجموها مسكينه
ترى اعتقد ما ابغى اجزم اعتقد انها بتيجي
هي وصديقاتها للسعوديه للسياحه وبدون عقد
بدون ما يدفع لهم معقوله معقولتين
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه وانا اعمل
الجريسي استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال
وقاده الراي ضيف حلقه اليوم هو الاستاذ
فهد حميد الدين الرئيس التنفيذي وعضو مجلس
اداره الهيئه السعوديه للسياحه حلقه مهمه
جدا لشرح مفهوم هويه المدن وتسويق المدن
وتسويق الدول واللي كانت هي البدايه اللي
صورنا فيها ثم دخلنا على ملف السياحه في
السعوديه ليش هذا الرهان الكبير من
السعوديه على ملف السياحه والدخول بثقل من
خلال الوزاره الهيئه المشاريع الكبرى
السياحيه والاستثمارات الضخمه في هذا
القطاع ليش هيئه وزاره وصندوق شرحنا ادوار
كل كل كيان من هذه الكيانات دخلنا في
موضوع
هل استعجلنا في فتح السعوديه وهي لم تكتمل
بناء التحتيه ومرافقها السياحيه كيف رضا
المجموعات الاولى من السياح اللي جو
وخاضوا هذه التجربه
هل كانوا راضين ويوصون بهذه التجربه
للاخرين تكلمنا على موضوع السفراء السياحه
لعيبه الكره المشاهير مثل ميسي وكريستيانو
كيف سفيرنا في السياحه ما يبغى يعيش عندنا
اللي هو ميسي
تكلمنا على موضوع ارتفاع الاسعار استهداف
اغلب المشاريع
للطبقه الاغنى في السعوديه وربما عدم وجود
خيارات الشريحه المتوسطه
وناقشتها بطبيعه الحال كل التفاصيل
الصغيره حقت هنقدر ننافس الدول المجاوره
لتقدم خيارات ارخص وش مقومات النجاح اللي
عندنا الى اخر هذه النقاط اترككم مع
الحوار حياك الله ابو ساره شرفتونا
ونورتونا الله يحييكم يا سعيد اني اكون
معكم الله يسعدك اخيرا صارت ارجع اشيك في
الواتساب اقول للناس من متى قاعد يحاول
فيها ولا ما يحتاج هذا السؤال
الله يسلمك
لا والله احنا سعداء بدنا نكسبك
وبنحكي عن ملفات رهيبه بس قبل ما نحكي عن
الملفات هذه
خليه خلينا نسمع منك حكايتك مع التنس لانه
اللي انا اعرفه اليوم انه في كذا موجه من
او يسمونه هبه البادل في 2019 2020
ناس اثبتوا وكملوا احتراف في هذا الموضوع
وراعين هبه الان حولوا التنس توهم في
التنس وكلمات تنس انت ما شاء الله من
الظاهر من سنين في هالموضوع هذا ووصلت
مرحله احترافيه وشو اللي يطيحك في التنس
هم قالوا لي انك انت بتطلع معلومات يعني
ما توقعها
عندي مصالح
يا طويل العمر أنا
ما كان لي في الكوره كثير
وكنت كان وزني كبير فكنت يعني شكلي دائري
اكثر من هذا الكلام عن عمري 12 13 الملعب
كره الكل يعلق وكنت اضايق فما عاد
العبد
انت اخر واحد يختارونه صح اللي يتورطون
اللي تورطون فيه بالضبط
ولا احد يلعب يعني انا ذاك فقلت هذه مساحه
بسيطه الين مجاني مدرب برازيلي
كان يكلم اخرين يقول ايه بس فهد يقول نظرا
ما حيجري
اذكر وقتها قلت انا لازم اقحف اذا بلعب
وفعلا يعني نزلت عن وزن
وقتك انت في اي مدرسه معهد العاصمه معهد
العاصمه انا طال عمرك انا ربعيتي هنا في
الرياض
درست معهد العاصمه وبعدين درست جامعه
البترول
ما رحت
بره
100% ما رحت خاصه قصتك
لا ولد
ترى في نظريه على فكره يقولون اذا قابلت
احد من البترول خلال 30 ثانيه لازم يعلمك
في البترول فما شاء الله عليك يعني صمدت
معنا دقيقه ونص لين علمتها انك رجل
البترول لازم كلكم تقولون المعلومه هذه
يعني ما شاء الله عليهم
بالموضوع فنرجع لموضوع التنس فانت اخذتها
كتحدي صحيح انك انت تنحف وسعادتك تنحف 27
كيلو
على ذاك العمر نتكلم احنا على يعني يمكن
نشوف صوري وانا عمري 14 سنه يمكن
هذا نفس الشخص
بس بعدين والحمد لله واحترفت ولعبت لمده
يعني السنين دخلت منتخب المملكه في التنس
وكانت تصنيف الثالث او ترتيب الثالث ومثلت
المملكه في بس بعدين خلاص اشتغلت ونسيت
ورجعت عشره لا لا لسه ما شاء الله امورك
امورك طيبه الحمد لله بس
يعني الفتره هذه ما عاد ترجع خلاص هذيك
علاقتك في انتهت يلا العب بابل شوي
يعني حقت ما يحتاج حركات الله يسلمك شكرا
ما شاء الله
عليك الحمد لله لا مبين وبديت العب تنس
فيعني ها قاعدين نحاول نبني المهاره هذه
ونمشي مع الهبه ونشوف وين بيودون الناس كل
سنتين رياضه جديده ونحاول نتعلمها خلاص
بس انت تقولي
احنا ابو ساره مبسوطين صراحه اليوم على
موضوع هيئه الهيئه السعوديه للسياحه ونبغى
نفتح الملف ونفهم دوركم ونفهم ايش سويتوا
بس في قبل التصوير سولفنا على موضوع هويه
المدن واسهبت فيه وانت رجل يعني
يعني ريادي وقياده في موضوع التسويق بشكل
عام فحبيت المفهوم اللي انت حكيت عنه في
موضوع التسويق المدن فبس ادخل في الهيئه
ومواضيعها انك تسولف لنا شويه على موضوع
ليش مهم موضوع هويه المدن وكيف هذه
الهويات تؤثر في الفرص وتؤثر فيه اقتصاد
المدن لما يصير عندها هويه واضحه
ممكن
ابتداء يعني قبل ما اتكلم عن الهويه
اي مدينه تنمو باقتصاد
ايش محركات النمو باي مدينه عندك
استثمارات عدد سكان يوسوق
منتجات وخدمات
اللي هي يعني تنمي التبادل التجاري داخليا
وخارجيا
وفيه سياحه استقطاب الزوار وينفقوا في اي
مدينه
فبالتالي اي مدينه عندها هويه المفروض ان
الهويه تؤثر على خمس
خمس انواع او خمس خطابات موجهه لشرح
مختلفه خطاب الاول اللي هو
استثمر في المدينه
الخطاب الثاني اللي هو زور المدينه فزت
احنا نقول روح روح السعوديه الخطاب الثالث
لاستقطاب كفاءات وكوادر للسكن في المدينه
وهنا جوده الحياه والفرص التعليميه
والتدريبيه
والرابع يمكن التعلم
كثير دول ما تروح عشان تعيش فيها بس تروح
تتعلم تدرس وترجع واخيرا
اذا تقول في بلد صنع في مثلا جبان ولا
اليابان ولا صنع في فرنسا مو زي صنع في
بعض الدول
الغير معروفه مثلا فكل ما كان عندك هويه
تخدم هالخطابات وتعزز قوتك في هالخطابات
كل ما ساعدت في التنميه الاقتصاديه على كل
مجال من هالمجالات الان بناء الهويات طال
عمرك في نظري
وشكرا على اطرائك يعني قد لا استحق لكن
هناك هويات صنعت بقصد وهناك هويات صنعت
بدون قصد
مثلا في دراسه قريتها عن
نيويورك نيويورك يقول لك انه اصبحت عندها
هويه انها في العالم او في امريكا كحد
ادنى يعني العاصمه بالضبط
تجي تشوف مليانه هم في الشوارع
مليانه جرائم مليانه وسخ بس ما تعرف
بمعروفه بها طيب كيف تكونت هذه الصوره
الذهنيه او هذه الشخصيه او الهويه عن
المدينه قال لك تقول للدراسه انه فيه فئه
من سكان المدينه ما تتعدى الفئه نسبتها من
5 الى 8% هي اللي تشكل هويته شخصيه
المدينه مين هذا الخمسه
هم ثلاث شرائح شريحه الاولى والاهم هم
رواد الاعمال والمحترفين
اثنين
التعليم شريحه يعني القطاع الاكاديمي
والثالث القطاع الاعلامي واذا هذول
الثلاثه اتحدوا
بتشوف تعظيم الاثر في بناء الهويه خل
نطبقها على نيويورك طبقها
احنا بنتكلم عنها عاصمه ماليه
المقرات المقرات الرئيسيه للبنوك كلها
متمركزه كلورس في نيويورك شوف اللي هم
المحترفين او بالضبط
وهنا العلاقه الوظيفيه بين الشركات دي
الموظفيها بتدربهم فاستحدثت برامج تدريبيه
في جامعات كبرى مثل مثل ما صار في نيويورك
هذا قطع الاكاديمي اللي هم الشريحه
الثانيه الشريحه الثانيه
في القطاع المالي هي بلومبرج مقرها
الرئيسي في نيويورك
هذول يتحدوا يبنوا هذه الصوره الذهنيه عن
هذا المدينه احنا على سبيل المثال في
الظهران المنطقه الشرقيه ترى تشكلت شخصيه
المنطقه الشرقيه زمان بناء على ارامكو
جامعه البترول
لقطع الاكاديمي والجامعه وجريده اليوم
هذ
ول المجتمع ترى ما كان يشكل كم الموظفين
ارامكو 22 الف وقتها
وطلاب ومنسوبي جامعه البترول 4000 انذاك
[موسيقى]
بهذه الطريقه اللي اليوم كان نقدر نقول
انه ظهران اكثرها يعني ترتيب تنظيم سواقه
جادين جدا بدري بالضبط
الاقل بكثير يعني من مئات الالاف اللي في
المنطقه الشرقيه
الان كيف احنا نستفيد من هذا المفهوم
اولا بس بوضح ان النيويورك ما عندها شخصيه
واحده اذا ينزل
لشرائح المهتمه ويمكن هي الاشهر او الصوره
الذهنيه الاشهر لا بس كمان هي كمان عاصمه
الفنون والمسرح البرودوي لكن تيجي تشوف
افضل مسارح في العالم في نيويورك
والمحترفين هناك سيناريوس اللي يكتبون
السيناريوهات اللي صمون الملابس الى اخره
جامعات الفاشل انتو هناك في نيويورك
الاعلام
كل الاعلام الفني المتمركز بين عندك بين
هوليود وبين نيويورك ونيويورك يخدم هذا
القطاع
الاواورد الاعلاميه في المسرح كلها في
نيويورك مقرها فتكونت هذا
الهويه الان الشطاره بالنسبه لنا ان احنا
ناخذ هذا المفهوم ونطبقه على
الهويات الموجوده او الهويات اللي لسه
بنصنعها لوجهات جديده بس مثلا نتكلم عن
هويه موجوده نبغى نعززها ونبنيها مدري
منوره المدينه هذه مدينه النور ومدينه
السكينه خذ السكينه السكينه
او كمفهوم المفروض ان احنا نعززه في
المدينه لان يخدم كل زوار وقاصدي هذه
المدينه
كيف تطورها على مستوى التشريع اذا بتكلم
عن السكينه من ابسط شيء امنع البواري الى
البناء الكود العمراني الاختيار الالوان
انه لازم من كل يعني بقعه في المدينه تشوف
الماذن ترى الجوار يعني هذا المدينه بكل
ما يعني لديها من تاريخ كيف الفت بين
المهاجرين
والانصار بالضبط
فيها كثير مواقع يعني
الرسول اللهم صل وسلم عليه كان يمشي الى
مسجد قبائل على رجوله دائما هذا المسار
اليوم جاده طوروها وانسنوها ونبغى نحافظ
على نفس
التجربه اللي ممكن الواحد يستحضر فيها
سيره الرسول اللهم صل وسلم عليه وخاصه انك
انت الى جواب مرقده جبل احد
احبه هو تاكيد على كلامك وبصاره انا هذا
الشعور بالضبط هو اللي جاني لما يعني جرت
المدينه عده مرات موضوع السكينه موضوع
الراحه وربطتها بي مثلا اللي يروحون مصحات
في في سويسرا ولا يروحون مصحات في اسبانيا
حتى يستجموا ولا حتى
يعيدوا الاتصال
بروحهم وهذه قطاع وسوق واعد جدا فارسلت لي
معالي الفياض رئيس مستشفى الملك فيصل
التخصصي كنت اقول يعني معاليك احنا ندفع
فلوس عشان نروح لاوروبا واحنا نقعد في
نهايه جوا منتجع ولا جوا مصحه تخيلوا هذا
موجود في فرع مستشفى التخصصي اللي في
المدينه المنوره انت ريدي روحانيا تتشافى
بوجودك في المدينه المنوره فما بالك لو
اضفت لها الجزء الطبي والجزء الاكلينيكي
او الجزء العلاجي اللي ممكن يتوفر في
منتجعات فانت هنا اذا تشكلت هويه المدينه
المنوره بهذا الطريقه انت جذبت حتى
المستثمر اللي يبني مصحه للاستجمام او
للاستشفاء في المدينه المنوره الطلاب
الجامعه الاسلاميه اللي قاعد يجون من
انحاء العالم بس حتى يكونوا جنب الحرم
النبوي
فيعني احنا عندنا هويه شبه مشكله ودك تبني
عليه وتعزز
في الاستثمارات زي ما ذكرت المصحات مراكز
الاستشفاء او حتى في
اقتصاديا اتكلم عن القطاع العقاري كثير
ناس تبغى تتملك
والرؤيه يعني اعلنت انه سيدي اسمه للعهد
اهلا انه حيكون في السماح للتملك للاجانب
حتى في يعني حتى في مكه والمدينه طب انا
اسالك سؤال شويه بس عفوا هذا الاقتصاديا
حيمثل فرصه هائله مش بس لمن يزور ولكن من
يكون عنده سكن هون بيت ثاني يكون مقصد لا
هو اللي يقاربه وهذا يعزز من عدد الزياره
والانفاق في المدينه وهذا وكلها تبني على
الهويه اللي هي السكينه وهنا بعد نقدر
نكمل الاجزاء الخمسه او خطابات الخمسه
اللي انت قلت عنها ميدنا المدينه مثلا
المنوره تمر من المدينه المنوره
وش وزنه بالنسبه للعالم الاسلامي لما تقول
هذه صادرات تمور من المدينه المنوره من
عجوه المدينه انت تتكلم على قصه مختلفه
فيعني هنا
عندنا فرص هائله واتمنى انه فعلا نبدا
نشوف هويات المدن تتشكل يعطيك
يمكن
مثال يمكن عجوه المدينه الان مصدره لكن
فكر في المنتج جديد
صنع في المدينه ماجد احد فكر فيه يمكن
اكيد يمكن في سبقوني ناس بس يعني ما قد
طرح كصناعه يمكن اطلع بقرشين بعد الحلقه
هذه جبل احد
وجبل الرماه
جبل الرمايه اليوم هي قصه غزوه احد الان
لما بالمقارنه مع روبن هود هذا اللي عنده
القوس والرمح ينباع لما تروح في بريطانيا
فيلد يقول لك 52% من مبيعات شفط رمح
روبنهاد بالله لكل هالمسلمين اللي ياتونه
بالملايين والمفروض يشتروا
رماح من المدينه كتذكار لهذا المكان
التاريخي ممكن يكون ريالين بلاستيك تجيب
الاطفال او يكون
جلد وخشبي ينباع بعشره الاف وهذا اقتصاد
هذا منتج واحد بس عندك القصه وعندك
الروايه والتاريخ والارث اللي يخليه يعني
منتج لازم تشتريه وانت هناك كل هذه امثله
لمدن تشكرت هويتها بالصدفه
ابي مثال لمدينه
بالتخطيط
هي شكلت هويتها كما تشاء وليس بالصدفه
نعتقد اللي تقوم به المملكه في العلا مثال
مثال حي على التخطيط
المقصود نتكلم عن مدينه متحف مفتوح متحف
تاريخي مفتوح تكلم عن الان بيطرحوها انه
يعني زيارتك
للعلا رحله عبر الزمن فعلا
ياخذوك الى الاف قبل الجيوب الدفندر
القديمه الطيارات
المراوح هذه التاريخيه القطار
يعني قيد الانشاء والتلوث البصري والتلوث
السمعي وكله مقنن للحفاظ على هذه رحله عبر
الزمن داخل المنتجعات الممنوع حتى الاسفلت
انت تتكلم على لون من لون التربه بالضبط
فبالتالي بنحاول بنحاول نحافظ على هذا
المفهوم انه يعني متحف تاريخي مفتوح
ومرورك في العلا او بقائك كانها تجربه في
رحله عبر الزمن وهذه كلها الاوتيلات معهد
تشوف علامات تجاريه واسواق برج زجاجي حتى
الابتكار الزجاج البرج المبنى الزجاجي كان
مرايه عشان يعكس لك هذا هذه يعني الاثار
اللي تركت لنا اياها الحضارات النبطيه او
من مره نتكلم عن العلا كمحافظه صغيره جدا
وبرضو في شغل على هويتها هل هذا يعني انه
كل المدن بحاجه الى هويه هل لازم يكون
عندنا هويه لكل مدينه انت قاعد اقول لك اي
مدينه لابد انها تبني اقتصادها
بحجم طموحها وحجم
امكانياتها او ميازهن تنافسيه ممكن ما
تكون عندها امكانيات لكن تستثمر فيها لانه
عندها نيه تنافسيه ممكن استغلالها الان
سؤالك هل لازم يكون لها هويه بقول لك هل
تسوق ولا ما تسوق كيف تبني منتج وما تسوق
له اكيد تسوق له ولازم تبني هويه لانه
هيعطيك التعظيم الاكبر مما بنيه ووفرت لي
الموجودين او الزوار
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
خلونا ندخل على على ملفنا بشاره الان
الاساسي في هذه الحلقه اللي هو موضوع
الهيئه السعوديه للسياحه
ويمكن نبدا اول شيء بدنا نقول ليش هذا
الرهان
المضخم من وجهه نظر بعض الناس من جانب
السعوديه في دهان مضخم على قطاع السياحه
فانشاء وزاره انشاء هيئه اربعه خمسه
مشاريع سياحيه عملاقه فيه يعني تسارع عجيب
في هذا الملف البعض حتى يقول مبالغ فيه يا
اخي في قطاعه اهم روحوا للتصنيع روحوا
للتعدين او لو اهم خلينا نبدا من ليش هذا
الاستثمار المضخم في قطاع السياحه
اعتقد ثلاث اسباب السبب الاول انه السياحه
كايقاع يساهم في بناء الناتج المحلي وتشوف
كل الدول الناجحه السياحيا القطاع السياحي
يساهم بعشره في المئه معدل عشره عشره في
المئه طبعا في بعض الدول اللي مرتكزه على
القطاع السياحي مثل المالديفز نسبه
المساهمه القطاع السياحي في الناتج المحلي
يصل الى 70% لكن نتكلم عن الدول
بمعد يعني معدلها
المساهمه تصل الى 10% او تتعدى 10%
بالسويد فاحنا عشره في الميه كحددنا حنا
كم بدينا بثلاثه في 2018 فبالتالي عندك
تنميه اقتصاديه بعيده عن النفط والمساهمه
حتكون ثلاثه اضعاف كحد ادنى لما كنا عليه
في 2018 السبب الثاني قد يكون هو الاهم
توفير الوظائف اليوم كل القطاعات قاعده
تودع وظائفها للاثمته
وتخسر وظائف للاثمته مجلس السفر او
السياحه العالمي يقول في العشر سنوات اللي
مضت كل
السياحه ساهمت بوظيفه من كل خمس وظائف
جديده او مستحدثه وبعد 2025 السياحه
حتساهم بواحد من كل اربع وظائف مستحدثه
فبالتالي الوظائف الجديده
المتوقع من القطاعات قاعده تنقص ومن
السياحه
حتزيد الان الاهم مش بس العدد ولكن النوع
ترى البطاله مشكلتها مش مع الوظائف الناس
اللي عندهم مشاهدات جامعيه وعندهم خبرات
تخصصيه كل ما نزلت في في مستوى التاهيل كل
ما وجدت ان البطاله تحدي اكبر
فعندك
السياحه تتميز انها توظف من الخريجين
الجامعات
والدراسات العليا الى خريجين الجامعه
الشهادات حاملين شهادات المهنيه الى
الحرفيين وتعطيهم فرص تطوير من ادنى يعني
من اول السلم الوظيفي الى اعلاه
واحنا يعني ما يخفى عليك تحدي البطاله
اكبر اكبر تحدي اقتصادي واجتماعي لنا
فالسياحه مش بس زيها زي قطاع يتميز بعدد
الوظائف ونوع الوظائف واخيرا السياحه
بتبني هويه المملكه كل زائر ياتي الى
المملكه لاي غرض كان بيرجع يقول انا صراحه
متفاجئ بما لدى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهذه التفاجئ
سمعه وهذه السمعه تزيد من الزوار وتزيد من
الرغبه في التعاون والتبادل الثقافي
التجاري ايا كان ويمكن يخدمنا حنا في
موضوع السمعه انه يعني الاعلام ما قصر 20
سنه وهو يشوش سمعتنا فاحنا بادين بنقطه
توقعات مره متدنيه اي احد يجي السعوديه
قاعد يطلع بانطباع ايجابي مو بالضروره
لانه كل شيء تمام بس لانه هو جاي بتوقعات
مره متدنيه نتيجه 20 سنه من اسمحلي اوكي
اتفضل
كثير يقولون اي الناس اصلا سمع سمعت
المملكه سيئه فكانت
سمعتها مشوهه من الاعلام كانت في بعض
الناس مشوهه
بمساوئ في اذهان الناس لانه الاعلام
الغربي كل اللي كان يهمه حروب
نشوف الاعلام ينقل عن
الدول حروب
مظاهرات مشاكل
يمكن صرع قوه سياسيه هذا اللي ينقل
الاعلام بشكل عام ما هي عمر العلم ينقل لك
والله بنينه
متاحف ولا
وظفنا مدري كم ولا طورنا ما يهتم بكل ما
هو ايجابي
احنا انا اعتقد المملكه العربيه السعوديه
صح قد تفاجئ البعض بان كان عنده الناس
مفهوم سائد مشوه لكن الاهم المملكه تفاجئ
اسوار بالدرجه الاولى هذا مو كلامي
مرصود عندي موثقافه احنا نسوي استطلاعات
للناس اللي تزور السبب الاول ما يقول لك
والله اني تفاجات بسبب الاول هو
المجتمع السعودي والسعوديه
مرحبين لطيفين كريمين منفتحين ما كنا
نتوقع ابدا هذا الشيء كلامك اثنين ما قد
شفنا هالت رحاب وهالحفاوه احنا على فكره
في الهيئه اخترنا مسمى يعني مصطلح الحفاوه
السعوديه كعنوان اصيل للضيافه العربيه
الحفاوه تشمل اكثر من مفهوم
ثلاث مفاهيم رئيسيه اول وحده الخدمه اذا
انت بتحتفي باحد اذا انا بحتفي فيك وانت
جايني
افضل خدمه لديك اللي اعرفها اثنين باكرمك
ثلاثه بهتم فيك حتى لو يجيك شيء طلب مالي
اي دخل فيه بقول كيف اساعدك وكيف اهتم فيك
فالاهتمام والرعايه والخدمه والكرم كلها
تندرج تحت يعني مصطلح الحفاوه فالحفاوه
السعوديه ستعيد مفهوم الضيافه العربيه
الاصيله وهي في جيناتنا يعني على وش وش
هالثقافه اللي جزء من تعاليمها وعرفها انه
يجيك الضيف الغريب ثلاثه ايام ما تساله وش
حاجتك ثلاثه ايام تضيفه تستقبله تكرمه ما
تفتح معاه اطلاقا ليش جيت ومن انت اي
ثقافه تصل بها درجه اكرام الضيف هذا
المستوى فاحنا عندنا هذا هذا
جائزه الجديده
يمكن كثير ما يستوعبون اهميه هذا الثقافه
انا ممكن اقول لب
اعزمي فلانه واهلها يجون عندك شافتهم في
الطياره وتقول لي بس يعني
بيستغربون
شيء ايجابي خليهم
بس في البدايه بيعرفون احنا صادقين واذا
جو شافوا في اي بلد ثاني فموضوع السياحه
هو يعني قطاع اقتصادي مهم فيه فرصه مهدره
فقط توظيف
الصوره الذهنيه اللي تم القوه الناعمه طيب
خلينا نسال ليش ليش بهذا الهيكل ليش وزاره
في فبراير 2020 تحولت الهيئه السابقه الى
وزاره بعدين في مارش بعدها بشهر تاسست
الهيئه السعوديه للسياحه وفي صندوق تنميه
سياحه وفي مجلس الاعلى للسياحه او شيء زي
كذا ليش بهذا الهيكل والشرق وشرق او دور
كل واحده من هذا الهيكل الوزاره هي من
يقود القطع الوزاره معنيه باستراتيجيه
القطاع
والترقي كمشرع يعني دورها الرئيسي مشرع
التراخيص التصاريح التفتيش على كل الشركات
والمستوى الخدمات المقدمه للسياح فنادق
شركات تنظيم رحلات
على سبيل المثال
الهيئه وايضا يبدو
اتكلمت عن اهميه القطاع السياحي تكمن في
التوظيف
الكادر التطوير الكادر البشري والتوظيف هو
يمكن
الاول والدور الاهم لدى الوزاره
بالنسبه للهيئه هي الذراع التجاري المعني
بثلاثه ادوار
التسويق والتسويق لزياره المملكه التسويق
والتشويق هذا وحده اوكي التسويق لكل
الاراضي اما بالنسبه للزياره مثلا زياره
الدينيه احنا نبغى نسوق حتى الاسر اللي
باطفالهم يجوا يعرفوا ابنائهم بمكه
والمدينه وما لديها من يعني
وجهات ومواقع تاريخيه الكل يحب يطلع عليها
الدور الثاني التوزيع والتوزيع هذا يمكن
الشق التجاري الاكبر والاهم ما يمكن سائح
يجي الا اذا فيه شركته كانت سفر وسياحه
اذا في شركه طيران اذا في فنادق في شركات
تنظيم اذا في منصات الكترونيه للحجز وهو
الى اخره الى المرشد فبالتالي هذا من يعمل
مع القطاع التجاري هي الهيئه الدور الثالث
قياس تجربه الزائر وتطويرها
هذا دور الهيئه الدور الثالث ذكرت انت
الصندوق الصندوق يمول كل المستثمرين من
الكبار الى الصغار الرواد الاعمال في
تطوير تجربه الزائر احنا نروح للوزاره
نقول لهم التجربه يبغى لها تطوير في هذا
هذا الجانب مثلا التاشيرات نروح لوزاره
السياحه وزاره السياحه تعمل معه نظرها من
وزاره الخارجيه والداخليه لتطوير وتسهيل
التاشيرات نروح لصندوق نقول نبغى نستثمر
في تطوير في التجارب
الوطنيه التجارب العيش مثلا في السكن
التجارب محليه ان كان اكل محلي او حتى
اقامه في بيوت ونزل ريفيه ونزل
صحراويه جبليه في الصندوق يعمل على صناعه
هذا التجارب مع القطاع الخاص
الثالث الجهاز الرابع عفوا اللي هو مجلس
التنميه السياحي قبل ما اشرح لك مجلس
التنميه وشدوره خلني اقول لك تجربه السلاح
تبدا طال عمرك يحجز تاشيره
الخارجيه
يركب الطياره اللي مرخصت له هيئه الطيران
المدني يوصل للمطار
الشركه الشركه يعني تعامل مع الشركه
وموظفين شركه
او مطورين او مشغلين المطارات
يختم جوازه عند الجوازات الداخليه يركب
اوبر ولا تكسي عندها يتنقل يروح للسوق عند
وزاره التجاره يروح للمتحف عن وزاره
الثقافه يروح يحضر حفل عند هيئه الترفيه
ينام
في الفندق عند وزاره السياحه فهذه السلسله
مين بينظمها مين بيتاكد انها تعطي
الاولويات اللي مهمه للسلاح احنا نروح
للوزاره والوزير هو رئيس مجلس التنميه
السياحي وعندنا
كل الجهات التي تعنى بهذا القطاع اللي
احنا نسميه قطاع رحله الزائره صحيح
وليس عمودي
وهذولي منظومه السياحه طيب في عفوا يعني
لما اقول قطاع افقي يعني لن تحقق مستهدفات
القطاعات كلها هذه الاشياء
حاصل
لا ترى جوده وكمل
100% هذه هذول ادوار الناس اللي
جيرانكم المنظومه طيب فيه الحاره اللي
جنبكم او او يعني اجهزه اخرى ما احنا
فاهمين كيف تتكامل معاكم اللي هي مثلا
هيئات الثقافه هيئه الترفيه وزاره الرياضه
هذول ايضا يقيمون فعاليات سياحيه وانشطه
سياحيه بالضبط وايش الفرق بينكم وبينهم
ودوركم ابدا انا اقول لك لما تكلمت عن
الجهات في رحله
لما يوصل الزائر يدور محتوى مين صنع
المحتوى هم اللي وزاره الرياضه في كل
الفعاليات الرياضيه من فورميلا الى
المباريات الى
حفلات
مواقع ترفيهيه
ومنظومه الثقافه صراحه يعني اليوم اللي
تقوم به منظومه الثقافه جزء يعني رئيس
احنا مرتكزين عليه في ترويج للمملكه من
مواقع اثريه من تنقيب الى حفاظ على تراث
ثقافي مادي وغير الى انتاج محتوى ثقافي
يتفاعل مع ثقافات العالميه
فكلهم مصدرين كلهم منتجين محتوى واحنا
دورنا ان احنا نستفيد من هذا المحتوى
ونسوق للعالم كل او كل بما يبحث عنه فانتم
تجيبون الزبون ثم
هذه الهيئات المختلفه تقدم تجارب مختلفه
لهذا الزبون صحيح
يمكن في انت يعني او نروح للجهات هذه
ونقول لهم مثلا نبغى نستقطب صينيين فنتكلم
الان مع نهايه الترفيه على يعني انتاج
محتوى جاذب
فتعاون بيننا احنا نجيب الناس بس نصنع
محتوى يجذب
صحيح يمكن انت تسويق فتعرف انه صعب تكون
الافضل في كل شيء او انك تجي تنافس احد
مكوش على الملعب حقه فاحنا دخلنا للسياحه
مره متاخرين يعني احنا نتكلم على عام 2019
فتحنا تاشيره السياحه والعالم واصل مراحل
متقدمه في المجال وش المقومات اللي تركز
عليها السعوديه للمنافسه عالميا اليوم
السائح عنده 196 ولا ما نعرف كم دوله في
الكره الارضيه كلهم يبغونه احنا جايين
متاخر مره على ايش نراهن لاقناع هذا
السائح انه يجي عندنا
ثلاث
يعني ثلاث يمكن
كل مساحه اثره من الثانيه المساحه الاولى
التنوع
طال عمرك
التنوع الثقافي اللي عندنا الجغرافي
اتكلم عن افضل صحاري في العالم اجمل
تضاريس صحراويه في العالم عندنا شوف كم
الناس اللي تبحث عن
احنا بيت الجري قريب من دونز هذه الخيار
الذهبيه احنا موطنها
وهذه ممكن في يوم تكون زي السفاري وزي
السكيف في اوروبا او السفاري في افريقيا
تعال تنوع الثقافه يتكلم عن الجبال
الجبال الثروات منطقه عسير
واليوم نقوم به بتطوير في الباحه ولا
الطائف ولا قمم السوداء هذه استغلال
التضاريس وما تقدمها للتضاريس من اجواء
بارده في منطقه يعني تلتهب في الصيف فاحنا
نتميز في فتره الصيف بهذا بعدين عندك
البحر بحر الاحمر وين تلقى شاطئ يمتد
لاكثر من 1700 كيلو متر بشعب باندر
الشعب المرجانيه ويعني
حياه فطريه بحريه لا يمكن ان تجدها في اي
مكان ولدها ناشونال جيوغرافيكس بتقول انه
عندك مناطق وصل افضل في العالم
فهذا تنوع جغرافيا تنوع الثقافي في كل
منطقه جغرافيه يعني جغرافيه وتضاريس
مختلفه تتشكل الثقافه وحتلقى من اكل الى
لبس الى الى بالضبط
ساحل اليوم يبحث عن ما هو جديد واحنا افضل
يعني منطقه
حافظنا عليها واليوم نفتحها للعالم بعدين
الامر الثاني
الارض الجزيره العربيه نحن الان
بنقدم السعوديه
هذه ارض الجزيره العربيه هذه الارض ميزه
هذه ارض يعني
ارض حضارات انبياء كل حراره تركت لنا ارث
مادي وغير مادي اليوم لما تشوف منظومه
الثقافيه اقول لك يعني فيه
بعثات اكثر من 27 بعثه اللي هم يسوون بحث
وتنقيب نحتاج احنا ندور ها الشواهد
الماديه الشواهد الماديه هذه اللي حنقدمها
للسائح
بس احنا بنتكلم عن قصص وموروث غير ماديه
شواذ الماديه تكمل القصه وتعطيك مكان
له عنوان تزوره
فاعتقدات نقدر ننافس
وزي ما قلت لك الحضارات والانبياء
الى مرورا بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه هذه
ارض يعني نتكلم عن
الانبياء وبعدين طبعا مهدي الاسلام واللغه
العربيه الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومن اللي بدات
من ثلاث قرون الى اليوم انا كنت اقول انه
المدن والدول مثل كان حي يستمر يعيش عنده
موروث لكن يطور اليوم احنا بنصيغ مودرن
اريبيا وحنبني
وحتكون حضاره يرصدها ترصدها دول وشعوب
اخرى
فعندنا الكثير من ما تركت له تركته لنا
هذه الحضارات ان قدمت ثلاثه قاعدين نبني
وجهات
استفادت من كل اخطاء الوجهات العالميه
الاخرى اليوم انا ما اتكلم بس عن يعني
الغير يعني غير مسبوق مثل مثل نيوم في فكر
وتخطيط وامكانات حتى في العلا حتى في عسير
حتى في اخطاء كثير شفناها في دول سبقتنا
واحنا نقول عندنا جيجا بروجكتس او
المشاريع
العملاقه العملاقه ترى هذه مسؤوليات
عملاقه لان احنا حنبني
مستفيدين من اخطاء الغير والحمد لله
القياده يعني ملتزمه انه لن نضحي بالبيئه
لن نضحي بالطبيعه لن نضحي وبالعكس وسناتي
ونطور وجهات ونوعيدها الى ما كانت كيف ما
كانت في عقود وقرون قرون مضت يعني اليوم
المحميات اكبر دليل في كيف احنا بنعيد
اعاده
ما نتاكد من الترجمه
بالضبط وانت بتشوف كما بنينا فبدينا في
العلا والملتزمين باكثر من 21 كائن
حيحنعيد
يعني بناء الحياه الفطريه لهم واستغرابهم
الى الارض اللي كانوا فيها قبل مئات
القرون السنين
[موسيقى]
الان احنا فهمنا ليش مهم موضوع السياحه
وايش وعندنا مقومات وعندنا مقومات والهيكل
حقنا تعالوا شويه ندخل بس عفوا اقول رغم
ان هذه القوه الثلاثه شوف هذه الثلاثه زي
اذا بقول
ثلاث طبقات اللي يربطها ثلاثه كلها هو
الانسان السعودي الحفاوه تحديدا الحفاوه
السعودي لا بد ان يعني نعززها ونحافظ
عليها
ونستمر في احيائها وتكريم افضل يعني افضل
امثله لمن يحييها وهذه يمكن اتوقع يجي دور
هنا الافلام ويجي دور والجوائز
ورواه القصص باشكالها المختلفه في كتب في
افلام في مسلسلات الكرم الاصيل الكرم
السعودي اللي اللي عبر التاريخ
كرمز الجزيره العربيه احد الى الان لم
يعطى حقه وفي قصص مذهله يعني قبل قبل
شهرين كنت في حايل وحايل من مناطق
السعوديه اللي اشتهرت بالكرم تاريخيا وحتى
في الوقت المعاصر وهم موطن حاتم الطائي
رمز الكرم العربي
فيسولف لي صديقي نادر الشمري عن عن
الفخذ اللي هو ينتمي له وكيف انه يعني
كانوا مجموعه وطالعين مع بعض وراح احد
منهم يبحث عن الماء انقطعوا فتره معينه
فانتصر في الطريق ورجع ما كمل وصول للمويه
قال اخاف اوصل واشرب وارجع والقاكم متو
يقولون ترك اخوياه فانا لا يمكن اشرب الا
وحنا سوا فرجع الربعه فيعني في شواهد وقصص
تقدر تطلع منها انت وترويها وهذه هي وسيله
تعزيز هذه القيم تثبيتها في الاجيال
الجديده لان الجيل الجديد قد يكون مفصول
نوعا ما عن هذا القصص وان شاء الله انها
تبدا بس انا هنا بسال شويه عن الهيئه
نفسها وخلصنا الكلام الحلو الحين وسع صدرك
معاي ابي ابدا الكلام اللي يمكن
نتناقش فيه اكثر يمكن قبل ما تسالني انا
بقول انه التسويق ليس على مستوى مدن فقط
حتى على مستوى فعاليات يعني له دور مره
كبير اليوم يعني انت تعرف السعوديه كان
الكثير يسافرون
اليوم
بدايه راس السنه كثير كانوا يسافرون عشان
الراس اليوم الناس تترقب راس السنه بس
الاهم شوف ايش سوينا في اليوم الوطني
الناس تترقب اليوم الوطني بفعالياته يوم
التاسيس كيف بنيناه ثقافي عظيم الناس
تستناه ويوم العلم قادم ان شاء الله
فالتسويق يعني على كل المستويات على مستوى
الدول على مستوى المدن على مستوى المراكز
وعلى مستوى الفعاليات تفضل
دائما لما احكي عن الهيئه السعوديه
للسياحه اسف تحملني الناس يقولون يا اخي
الله يعطيكم العافيه بس
ملخبطين يا اخي احس ما هو مرتبين فجاه
تلاقي لوح اعلانات في مكان ما له دخل او
يمكن
ما حدا يناظر الاماكن هذه بالتكلفه هذه
وحندخل على المشاهير يتوقعون معاهم
وتجيبونهم بس ودي تعرفنا على ايش بالضبط
سوت الهيئه من يوم ما بدات
كاثر وليش هذا الانطباع عنكم
اولا انا ما يعني ما ادري انت مين تتكلم
لكن افترض انه هذا انطباع لا شوف موضوع
التسويق في
في كل كل وظيفه او مكان عمل انا اشتغلت
فيه
مساحه يفتي فيها كل
واحد التسويق والاعلام لانه يعني
انا ادرى واعرف
احنا نداعي احنا يعني تقنيين جدا في ما
نقوم به من التسويق وعندنا قياس
لثلاثين الف مستهدف
32 الف تحديدا سنويا نقيس انطباعات
انطباعاتهم على المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ورغبتهم في الزياره واستعدادهم للحجز
ونيتهم للحجز اكثر من مستوى لانه استعداد
شيء استعديت هل نويت انا ممكن اقول لك قد
رحت
اول ما سمعت عنها هل على طول رحت ولا قاعد
فتره
زي اي منتج يطرح احنا الان في الساحه
السياحيه
طرح منتج جديد اسمه السعوديه هل اذا دريت
عنه بتروح لا تقول
افكر بعدين تقول نعم او يمكن تقول لا
السعوديه ما اعتقد ان اهلي
والله مستغرب والله شفت ممكن نويت اخطط اه
لا مو السنه دي ان شاء الله السنه اللي
بعده فالان اللي يقولون ليش تسوقون من
الان ترى المملكه جاهزه ترى المشوار
القرار يؤخذ يعني العزم والنيه والحجز ما
ياتي الا بعد سابع
نيه حجز عالميا تجي بعدين تتكلم عن اللي
ما قد زاروه اتكلم عن دول الجوار واللي قد
زاروا كثير
اثنين الناس تقول ليش تعلن في هالوقت مين
بيجيك في هالوقت
الوقت بالنسبه لنا هو فتره الحجز وما يسمى
البوكيموندو كل بلد لهبه مختلف
يعتمد على الجداول الدراسيه ويعتمد على
القرب وهو يعتمد على العادات عندهم اعطني
مثال اعطيك مثال الخليج يقرروا في خلال
اسبوعين ثلاثه يروحون
اليابانيين ياخذون ثمانيه شهور امريكا
اربع شهور يعني البوكينج ويندوز اذا ما
جيتهم قبل باربع شهور جايين
فبالتالي انت في منظورك قد ترى انه والله
مو هذا الوقت
اول تكلمت عليه الانفاق الثانيه الوقت
الثالث
والمحتوى هل هذا هو المحتوى سواء احنا
نسوي
ناخذ جروبات 130 شخص
ونعرض عليهم صور ونقولهم وشفتوا ايش عجبكم
هل يحفزكم ولا لا نفس الشخص نعرض عليه من
خمسه الى ست صور ونشوف وش اللي حركة
الصيني يختلف عن
البلجيكي والمراه غير الرجل والام غير
الشابه
والكبار السن غير
عشان كذا لما تشوف الاعلان
ينقص ويتقطع يعني لما نصور اعلان نصنع
يعني نطلع 52 نسخه
عشر ثواني ست ثواني طبعا حسب القناه وحسب
المستهدف وحسب
التاريخ بس فانا اقصد مو الكل يدرك
وانت ايش قلت قلت انفاق قلت توقيت يمكن
قلت محتوى
وقلنا بشكل عام انه الناس تشوف كانه فيه
عدم ترتيب في شغل الهيئه بشكل عام ما ادري
كيف وصل لهم هذا الانطباع هل لانه مثلا
تنشافون او الدور بعدين
تنشفون لاعب يعني لو تشرح لنا باختصار ترى
باختصار احنا لابد ان احنا نكون في كل
مكان هم الشخص متعود انه انت هيئه خلاص
وريني شغلك واقعد فيه
سمعه بلد أنا وين اطلع باسم الهيئه
السعوديه
للسياحه اطلع باسم روح السعوديه او فيزا
سعوديه وبالتالي هذا الشعار المملكه اللي
نسوق فيه كل من يقوم بكل
يعني وينتج كل محتوى او يبني كل وجهه او
يتعاقد مع اي لاعب ترى على فكره
كمان الانطباع ياتي من عدم استيعاب انه
هذا الهيئه وش دخلها لا بالعكس الهيئه
لابد انها تقتنص كل ما هو جديد من محتوى
ومنتج ووجهه وتجربه للترويج عنها لاستقطاب
السياحه طيب وش سويتوا وش حققته من يوم ما
بديته الى اليوم
جميله
طبعا احنا لما في بلدينا اطلقنا
الاستراتيجيه
اعلنها عن مستهدف 100 مليون زائر او زياره
بنهايه 2030
بازال ترى البعض ما هو ما هو واضح له ايش
معنى زياره زياره يعني المبيت ليله واحده
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه او في اي
مدينه يسافر لها اذا كانت اذا كان
الهدف 100 مليون 100 مليون زياره من
الداخل الخارج ولا بس الخارج من الداخلوا
الخارج ويوم على الناس كم كنا واصلين 54
مليون صحيح فانت كنت تبغى تدبل الرقم خلال
عشر سنوات نعم
اسلم طبعا علما انه احنا كنا بادين نتكلم
عن الاغراض الزياره كلها الزيارات
الزيارات الدينيه
زيارات الاعمال زياره الاهل والاصدقاء
وزيارات
اللي نعرفها السياحيه اللي هي زياره
المتعه ان كان استجمام ولا ثقافه ولا
رياضه ولا
من 2018
حطينا مستهدفات لكل انواع الزياره وزياره
محليه داخليه وزياره خارجيه
بالنسبه لنا الزياره الداخليه كانت احد
اهم النقاط التركيز لانهم المفروض
اول ناس نبدا فيهم لاكثر من سبب السبب
الاول يعني اذا ما قلعته اللي هنا عندك
بالضبط تماما وخاصه خاصه
ان هذا السبب الثاني انه السائح السعودي
الاعلى انفاقا في العالم
ثلاثه السائح السعودي حيقنع المستثمر
السعودي انه يستثمر لانه فيه طلب محلي لما
تقفل الابواب مثل ما صار في الجائحه او
لاي
شان امني سياسي ايا كان
الاقتصاد هذا
سيقاوم بما لديه من سياحه داخليه واذا كان
المستثمر المحلي استثمر حيجيك المستثمر
الاجنبي ويقول انا بدخل اشارك وابني على
ما لديك فالساحه الداخليه يمكن كانت اكبر
هدف لنا او اول هدف لنا والكثير كان يتحدى
يقول انه اول ما يفتح تفتح الابواب بعد
الجائحه الناس كلها بتهز وبتسافر صحيح في
فتحت الدنيا كيف الامور اليوم السائح في
22 اقدر اقول
السائح المحلي وصل الى 77 مليون زياره
الزياده سنويه باضطراد
واعتقد ان هذا بيخلينا يعني نعيد النظر في
اصلا صراحه يعني اذا احنا قبل التاشيره
وقبل المشاريع الكبرى وقبل العلا وقبل
الدنيا هذي اربعه وخمسين معقوله هدفنا في
12 سنه بس ندبل هالرقم ما هو بهذا العشم
في اهداف السعوديه عاده الاهداف الناس
يقولون اصلا اهداف مبالغ فيها والاهداف
الوطنيه كذا دائما توسم اهداف السعوديه
فغريبا اهدافكم شلون مررتو على الهدف
البسيط هذا لا انت ابدا ما هو بسيط لان
المعيار الحقيقي ليس
بالعدد هو الاثر للعدد والاثر ياتي من
العدد ومعدل الانفاق
في الحقيقه النجاح الحقيقي انك انت يعني
تاتي بدبل لكن نوع هذا الدبل وتشكيله يعني
تشكيله هذا الفئات اللي انت استقطبها هي
اللي حتدفع وتنفق في بلدك اكبر بكثير من
الخمسين
وساره وقل لنا
بالضبط وايش كان دوركم في ناس يقولون اغلب
هذا الرقم جاي من المعتمرين واللي هم الله
يخليهم انا موجودين من زمان قبل ما انتم
تجون قبل ما تسوون اي شيء دوركم انتم في
ال54 اللي صارت 93 مليون
اولا شكرا على هذا السؤال فعلا هذا السؤال
يجيني في المجالس ويجيني من الكل طال عمرك
احنا لما تكلمنا عن 100 مليون زياره كنا
نتكلم عن كل الزيارات لكافه الاغراض من
الداخل ومن الخارج
مليون زياره زياره تعرف بان الانسان يسافر
الى مدينه ويبيت فيها لو ليله واحده هذه
تعد زياره بالنسبه لنا الاغراض تشمل كافه
الاغراض الاربعه ان كانت سياحه اللي هي
تسالني عنها مثلا
المتعه استجمام رياضه ثقافه بحر ايا كان
او الاعمال زياره الاغراض الاعمال او
زياره لغرض زياره الاهل والاصدقاء او
زياره الدينيه واحنا تشرفنا بخدمه ضيوف
الرحمن
وخدمه الحرمين ولابد ان احنا انه يعني
نبدا بهذا كاولويه ان احنا نرفع هذا العدد
ولا الرؤيه نصت على مستهدف انه نرفع عدد
الزياره الزوار المعتمرين ما اتكلم عن
الحج المعتمرين الى 30 مليون زائر بنهايه
2030 الان المعتمرين ايش دورنا فيما احنا
بالنسبه للهيئه عندنا ثلاث ادوار رئيسيه
كزائر عندك سمعه واحنا مسؤوليتنا تطوير
اسمعه اليوم تطوير السمعه او تحسين السمعه
عن تجربه العمره ما كان احد يتكلم عنها ما
كان احد يتكلم عن تسهيلات التاشيرات بوضوح
او التطوير المطارات او القطار الحرمين
الخ الى كل
اصبح يسير ما زال في اذهان الكثير عسير
فيما يخص تجربه العمره
هذا دور اول دور الثاني واطلقنا منصه نسك
يمكن في الدور الاول اطلقنا منصه نسك اللي
تحاكي منصه
لانك انت تبغى تطلع وتعرف معلومات تعريف
وتشويق وتخطيط تساعدك على التخطيط
للاغراض كلها حطينا واللي غرض زياره مكه
والمدينه
حطينا منصه نسكت دوت اس اي بالتعاون مع
وزاره الحج والعمره وبرنامج ضيف الرحمن
الدور الثاني كان تطوير
الخطوط الجويه عبر الناقلات الوطنيه
والعالميه وسيرنا رحلات وخطوط جديده ما
كانت موجوده
وجدنا عدد المقاعد ثالث الثالث هو تطوير
ومساعده الشركات وسلاسل الامداد الشركات
المقصود بها وكاله سفر والسياحه
منصات الحجز شركات تنظيم الرحلات وشركات
تنظيم العمره ترى هذولا ما كانوا يعني ما
كان عندهم احد يدعمهم يوجههم ويساعدهم في
التطوير اليوم فيما يخص زياره العمره احنا
اشتغلنا مع كافه الشركات في هذا السلسله
وساعدناهم تطوير باقات
للترويج لباقاتهم والوصول من خلال شركات
الطيران وين منصات الحجز الدوليه الان هل
في زائر ياتي لغرض واحد اقول لك اغلبهم لا
الغالب يجي ان كان اعمال ويروح يتفسح وفي
حالتنا اذا كان مسلم يجي للاعمال وبعدين
يزور يعتمر
فبالتالي في تداخل بين الزيارات لذا الان
احنا وحدنا زياره اعلنا عن التاشيره
الجديده تاشيره زياره موحده لاي غرض كان
فدورنا يشمل كل هذه الادوار وعلينا مستهدف
لرفع عدد المعتمرين مثل ما علينا رفع عدد
الزيارات باغراضها المختلفه بس خلينا نمسك
الارقام ابو ساره كم زاد عدد المعتمرين كم
زاد عدد
الزائرين من الخارج اللي هم نوعا ما
التحدي الجديد او المهمه الجديد عليكم
لانه بقيه الاغراض كانت موجوده قبلكم
ومستمره يمكن سهلت شويه في تاشيرات لكن
الرهان الحقيقي انك تقنع واحد ما كان يخطط
السعوديه انه يجي حق الاعمال من زمان ودهم
يجون بس كان الباب مقفل العمره قائمه
ومستمره لكن الزائر اللي من بره كم كنا
وكم صرنا وهل الفرق هذا في موضوع الاثر
الاقتصادي اللي كنا نحكي فيه في بيئه
الحلقه
شوف احنا عندنا هدف
تمديد مده البقاء لكل الاغراض وبالنسبه
للزياره المتعه والسياحه ان احنا نستحدث
هذه ونجذب وناتي بارقام ونرفع الارقام
الان اليوم عدد الزوار من الخارج 16 في
اثنين عام 22 انتهينا ب 16 مليون و500 الف
المستهدف للعام القادم 25 مليون احنا
اليوم في منتصف العام احنا بنصور في منتصف
العام
والحمد لله تخطينا
25 مليون
على اساس نوصل ان شاء الله الى 25 انتقالا
من 16 ونص العام الماضي زياره وليس سائح
هذا الزياره بالتعريف اللي اتفقنا عليه
بالضبط لكل الاغراض وكلها في في زياده
وعندنا تارجتس لكل لكل غرض كم كان رقم خط
الاساس
في 2018
كان 54 مليون زياره منها
ثمانيه مليون
من الخارج ثمانيه مليون الاغراض لكل
الاغراض في اليوم الثمانيه مليون كانت وقت
بدايتكم اليوم صارت في اخر سنه 16
ومستنه هذي 25 مليون زياره من الخارج صحيح
طيب بالنسبه للانفاق انا اعتقد الانفاق هو
المعيار الحقيقي للنجاح لانه اذا ما زاد
العدد وزاد الانفاق هذا بحد ذاته افضل
نجاح ليش لانه تجربه الزائر ما بتخرب
بازدحام وازدحام ازدحام في المواقع او
ازدحام مروري او ازدحام ايا كان في
المطارات
فعشان كده يمكن
لو تشوف المعيار الحقيقي للنجاح كم زاد
الانفاق وكم المستهدف بنهايه 2020
بدينا طال عمرك ب165 مليار انفاق في عام
الانفاق من
كل الزائرين كل الزوار داخل الخارج
والمستهدف في
نهايه عشرين ثلاثين 561 تكلم عن اكثر من
ثلاثه ضعاف بينما الزياده في العدد من
خمسين مليون الى 100 مليون
الانفاق المفروض انه يكون اكثر من ثلاثه
اضعاف معناته النجاح مش استقطاب مثل العدد
وانما تغيير الفئه المستهدفه ومعدل
الانفاق ونوع السائح وغرض الزياره واليوم
احنا كم وصلنا في هذا الانفاق
في عام 22 ارتفعنا الى 184 مليار
وما كان في حج يعني لو تضيف هذاك 160
شاملا للحج اوكي زياده لكنها طفيفه نظرا
لان الحج مكان بالاعداد الطبيعيه صحيح
يعني لما نقول هدف مئه مليون وانت اليوم
واصل 93 مليون زياره
قبل ما تفتح المشاريع الكبرى وقبل ما
يستانف قطاع السياحه طاقته الكامله بعد
الجائحه غريبه شلون مرته الهدف الغير طموح
هذا احنا متعودين اهداف الرؤيه طموحه جدا
لاقرب الى الخيال اقرب الى الصعوبه
التحقيق يسمونه اهداف افلاطونيه من كثر ما
هي صعبه شلون انتم مررتو هدف بس انكم
تضاعفون مره واحده في عشر سنوات غريبه هذه
اولا احنا العدد كان كبير لانه عندك عمره
وعندك اعمال مثل ما ذكرت
والمملكه يعني فيها اهل واصدقاء وزياره
اهل واصدق مرتفعه في خط الاساسي اللي
بدينا فيه نوعا ما مرتفع والمئه مليون
بيحط من وصف افضل خمس دول في العالم فقد
لا يكون افلاطوني في نظرك لكن كوننا احنا
نكون المصاف افضل خمس دول في العالم هذا
بحد ذاته معيار يعني الامور تقاس بالتقييم
وبالقياس فاليوم تقيس بالدول الثانيه تشوف
ان رقم كبير ولكن اتطمن رقم بيزيد رقم
بيزيد انا اعتقد ومتاكد انه ما حد كان
متوقع الزياده الكبيره في الزياره المحليه
السياحه المحليه يعني احنا نتكلم عن 93
مليون العام الماضي
77 مليون منها
من الداخل
الان السياحه الداخليه انا ذكرت لك انها
الاهم لانه السعودي هو الاعلى انفاقا في
العالم ولان السعودي متطلب ويرفع الجوده
واكثر واحد اذا ما عجبت الخدمه بيقول لك
بيخرجهم يقول لك ضبط الخدمه
في الاعلام الاجتماعي
فبالتالي السياحه الداخليه نموها الغير
متوقع هذا بحد ذاته نجاح كبير
لان لسببين واحد في انفاق محلي والناس
تقول
يعني داخل اهم من اعاده تدوير
الانفاق او الاقتصاد الداخلي هذا ترى ما
كان موعده تدوير هذا كان بيطلع برا فاحنا
الان حافظنا عليه
وشجعنا القطاع الخاص للاستثمار احنا نتكلم
على موضوع جهودكم بشكل عام قفلنا سالفه
الارقام وش حققته في زياده الزوار اباك
الحين تنتقل للجزء الثاني او الملف الثاني
اللي هو ايش سويته في موضوع القطاع وتمكين
الشركات والتوزيع هذا الطلب اللي قاعد
قاعدين تجبونه
الاثر على شركات القطاع على الجهات
العامله في القطاع يمكن انت سالتني عن
مشاركاتنا والمعارض الدوليه اول معرض دولي
رحنا فيه كان في هذا الماركت الاي تي ام
رحنا ما معنى 19 شركه والشركات هذه او جهه
من وجهات او شركات تنظيم رحلات
بعد سنتين ونص رحنا في الاي تي بي في
برلين كان معنا سبعين شركه بس الاهم
ان احنا مكناها شركات انها توقع عقود لانه
كل وكاله السفر العالميه تروح لهذه
المعارض الدوليه عشان تشوف وش عندك غرف
وايش عندك تجارب وايش عندك
مقاعد على طيران فلما نروح المعارضه
الدوليه ناخذ خطوط الطيران وناخذ الفنادق
وناخذ الشركات التنظيم الرحلات نقدم كل ما
لدى المملكه من
يعني لدينا في المملكه من منتجات سياحيه
توفر كامل التجربه
الخارجي يجي يشتري ويحجز
شركات تنظيم رحلات لكن عندهم
منصات الكترونيه الفنادق ما كان عندهم
بودره مبيعات ترى مدره مبيعات في الفنادق
عندنا كلها مدره مبيعات
افراح وكذا تعال وريني تسعيره الغرف حقك
اللي بعد سته شهور بعد سنه الى 8 الى 18
شهر اللي يطلبوه الشركات
خطوط الطيران ما كانوا كلهم يشاركون معنا
واذا راحوا يشاركوا ويشاركوا بمعرض كبير
جميل يتكلموا عن الكراسي بس وين الخطوط
وين فاليوم انت تشوف الانتفاضه في القطاع
والنمو الهائل في الشركات
والمشاركه انعكست في كم من العقود اللي
قاعد يتوقع في كل هذه المعرض والحمد لله
الحمد لله المملكه في كل معرض بتحقق انجاز
افضل من يعني من اللي قبله اخر واحد كان
في برلين يعني كنا نطلب بعض الاجتماعات في
السنوات اللي راحت وما نقدر نحصل على يعني
لقاء المسؤولين الكبار ان كانوا رؤساء
مجالس خطوط او رؤساء مجالس شركات سفر
واعلان
بدون ذكر اسماء اقدر اقول لك في برلين
اعتذرت من كثير من بعض الشركاء اللي يجوا
في اخر لحظه
وبعض ورئيس مجلس اداره وحده الخطوط جاني
للمعرض يقول ادري انك مشغول لو اقابلك بس
خمس دقائق فالحمد لله
في هذه الرحله البسيطه في في تعاملنا مع
الشركات
عالميا اقدر اقول لك انه انتقلوا من ناس
كانت تمر وتطنش وتمشي ونحاول ندعوهم وما
يستمعون معنا الى تمر وتراقب وشك قاعده
تسوي السعوديه الى اليوم تجي وتنتظر وتعمل
معنا وهذه خلال سنتين ونصف مشاركاتكم في
المعارض
والشركات قاعده تسوونها مع جهات المختلفه
لانه الدور الثاني مثل ما قلت استقطاب
السياح وتكلمنا عن الارقام الدور الثاني
هو التوزيع وسلاسل الامداد من خلال تطوير
ما تقدمه الشركات القطعه الخاص من ضمن
الجهود حسب صرفنا في حلقه سابقه مع
المدني موضوع
تحفيز الخطوط على
يعني
تسير رحلات ربط الجوي ربط الجوي هذا ايضا
كان لكم جهود فيها
الهيئه طال عمرك هي اللي مطلوب منها تحدد
الوجهات او المدن المفروض ربط الجوي يركز
عليها ويبدا فيها الهيئه عندها
دراسات تقدمها لبرنامج ربط الجوي بناء على
معدل الطلب من هذه المدينه ونسبه استعداد
الناس انك كنت اقول لك انه احنا نقيس
سنويا 32 الف شخص في مدن مختلفه 27 مدينه
ونتابع كل ست شهور بناء على الارقام نقول
المتوقع الطلب المتوقع من هذا المدينه
يهدي يعني يغطي مثلا اربعه رحلات اضافيه
من هذه المدينه من من
جلاسكو ايا كان
فاحنا نروح
للبرنامج ربط الجوي ونعطي التوصيه انه هذه
الخطوط اللي نحتاجها كاولويه ونبدا
ايا شركات بس هذه التوصيات ترى مو محدوده
بس ايش الخطوط الربط يعني الخطوط اللي
نربط عليها كمان التوصيات اللي تروح
لمنظومه السياحه لانه برنامج ربط الجوي
انبثق من استراتيجيه السياحه فنروح
لوزاره السياحه اصيب بتسهيل مثلا
التاشيرات او نوصي بتطوير مثلا
الكادر البشري لهذه لهذه الدوله او نروح
لمثلا نطور
الوجهات السياحيه مثلا اليوم تجي لمدينه
مثل الرياض الكثير يتكلم عن التحديات اللي
واجهها في المدينه في في الطرق في الطرق
المورينجا كانت سواقه ولا ولا ترافيك يعني
الزحام وهذا في اسير في الموسم الصيف
فالان ازدحام احد اهم العوائق عندنا
لتنميه السياحيه فالان كيف تعالجها تتكلم
عن النقل حنتكلم عن
التخطيط الوجهات فاليوم لو تروح اي مدينه
مثل لندن تلقى في احياء سياحيه هذه
الاحياء تقدر تقول احياء متكامله فيها كل
الخدمات فانا اطلب اوصي لوزاره السياحه
انه في تطوير الوجهات نحتاج احياء متكامله
مثلا الرياض الدرعيه حتكون حي متكامل
احياء لا لا خلي حتى في الرياض مثلا ممكن
يكون في اوتيلات معارض مطاعم تنزل
الرياض بوليفارد
اللي قامت بهيئه الترفيه اليوم بداوا
يحطوا اوتيلات بتتحول الى احياء متكامله
كمان في يعني كل مدينه عندها فرصه انها
تبني احياء متكامله تستقط تنزل فيه تتمشى
فيه تاكل فيه تشتري فيه اساس ما تضيع وقتك
في الزحام في موضوع
صحيح دخلنا الموقع حقهم في الوجهات اللي
يصوم بها او اللي يعني
يسوقونها وما لقينا ولا وجهة سعوديه في
الموقع حقهم ما ادري مين اللي دخل بس انا
اقدر اقول لك
سكرين شوت ما لقينا اي وجهه سعوديه ضمن
الخيارات الاولى هذا الكلام الى قبل تصوير
الحلقه بساعات طيب ابشر نحاسبهم بس المهم
عليه ادائهم اوكي اليوم اذا في خط غير
ناجح والنجاح ان عدى 77% من المقاعد
مليانه اذا كان المقاعد مليانه ليش احط
فلوسها سوق اليوم عندنا معدلات تفوق ال
94% ما يحتاج تروج لهذه الخطوط
احنا شغلنا معهم 23 خط من 23 خط اربع خطوط
فقط اللي تحتاج تسويق ثلاثه منها او اثنين
منها من ايطاليا لو ترجع للموقع حقهم قبل
شهرين اطلقنا معهم
رحله
الرحله بلاين تريب
عمياني طلعنا 100 مسافر معهم مع وزير مئه
مسافر ما يدرون وين بيروحون
واكشن موجود الفيلم في الموقع حقهم لانه
هذه هم اللي اشتغلوا معنا على هم اللي
راحوا للمطارات
واقنعوهم انه السائح حيجي وموقع ما يدري
وين بيروح فلازم نخفي في الشاشه بنقول
رحله رقم كذا الوجهه غير معروفه جيت بوابه
رقم كذا وسواها في مطارين وجو المئه سائح
بعوائلهم باطفالهم ومشيناهم واليوم هذه
الاربع خطوط باذن الله تصل الى
77% من الاشغال في كمان يعني انا بقول لك
في باب يعني بعض الزملاء يقولون ترى يا
اخي هذه الطيران قاعد يشيل ناس ما يجيب
ناس اقول لك 70% من البوكينج على
من خارج المملكه
بس الاهم احنا ما نعطي ان سنترف على
المقعد اللي يتعبى من الداخل احنا نعطي
حافز فقط على المقعد الجاي وهم عليهم
يعبوا في كلام كثير ابو ساره على انه ترى
مستعجلين حنا بعدين نسوق
ونفتح البيبان ونروج للسياحه السعوديه
واحنا ما بعد جهزنا لا البنيه جهزت
للمنتجعات حقت الدرعيه والبحر الاحمر
اكتملت قاعدين نخسر الفرصه حقه انه هذا
اذا جاك حيجيك اول مره فاذا ما انت جاهز
خلاص انت خسرت الانطباع الاول ورجع زعلان
وشفنا بعض الناس صوروا مقاطع في اماكن ما
هي مريحه بعض الناس تصور مواقع لمواقف ما
هي مريحه مع سائق تكسي او سائق اجره هل
استعجلنا بترويج السياحه السعوديه
الاجابه ابدا ما استعجلنا والكلام مو
برايي هو راي السائح حال خروجه من المملكه
احنا عندنا قلت لك ثلاثه ادوار للهيئه
الدور الاول استقطاب السياح والترويج
الدوره الثانيه اللي هو تطوير سلاسل
الامداد مع القطعه الخاص الدور الثالث هو
اللي يعني بما ذكرت
تجربه الازاح الزائر او السائح التجربه
تقيس نقاط نقاط الالتقاء بالوجهه في 120
نقطه يعني
ركب الطياره دخل الطياره وصل للجوازات ركب
السياره في المطار
تاخر العفش فاحنا نقيس 200 وعشرين نقطه
التقاء
ونشوف في الاخير
ناخذ 4000 شهريا راندوم على كل مدينه
زاروها اجانب
ونسالهم فيه مصطلح اسمه انقياس
بمعنى نت يعني الزبده
بتروج بتنصح بهذا الوجهه ولا لا اذا كان
انطباعك سيء ما حتنصح فيه ما حتنصح فيها
اذا كان الام بي اس بالماينس بالسالب نوقف
اجابه لمن يعني يسال هالسؤال ما وصلنا
سالب وصلنا في فتره الصيف كنا نروج لاحدى
المدن
وكانت النتيجه
بالسالب وقفت وكان فيه يعني
مقاومه مقاومه خاصه يعني المنطقه واهلها
وتجارها كانوا يقولون يعني وصلت الى
المسؤولين في المنطقه انه كيف تشيلونا من
المنطقه هاد
بس وقفناها
السياح كانت
المشكله الحاره
ولا كان فيه تجارب يعني مغلقه او مغلقه او
مسقوفه او كذا خاصه في مواقع اللي كنا
بنروج لها وطورناها وفتحناها
بالايجاب
واجمالا كم كم كانت درجاتها او ارقامنا في
هذا المؤشر هو انت تقيس من يعني بالسالب
الى 50 هو 100 من زيرو نيوتن
انصح فيها ولا ما انصح فيها والله
اذا كان بالسالب لا اذا وصلت الى ماينس
فيفتي انتبه تحذير من الزياره بالضبط
اني اقول للناس انتبهوا لاحد يروح شباب
ترى هذا اللي صار لي لا احد يروح الى
بلس خمسين من واحنا الان
طبعا انت تراوح لغرض السياحه والشريحه ومن
اي بلد بس انا اقدر اقول احنا بالموجب من
11 الى
بالاجابه وانا اقدر اقول لك ترى يعني
كثير وجهات يعني متقدمه عايشه على الخمسه
الى ثمانيه اوكي بالاجابه بس اقدر اقول لك
خليني اقول لك شيء لانه الكلام اللي انت
طرحته صحيح ترى تجربه عندنا البنى التحتيه
انا ترى ان البنيه التحتيه ممتازه ولا
اتكلم عن الطرق والزحام ما نتكلم ترى
مستوى السواقه حتى يخوف الناس اللي
يستاجرون سيارات وعندنا تحديات كثيره
وتروح ما تلقى مثلا مرشدين بكل اللغات
فاحنا قاعدين نبني هالقطاع
لكن ايش
السبب الاول لانطباع الانطباع الايجابي
عند الناس هو السعوديين هو الترحاب هو
الحفاوه السعودي اللي تكلمنا عنها هو اللي
يجيك واحد في الشارع ويبتسملك انت جاي
سايح كذا لقافه بس هذا اللقافه محببه عند
السياح ويقول لك
وش عجبك وش اللي ما عجبك هذا الانفتاح
بقلوب الناس قبل كلامه هذا مو مسؤول ترى
اذا واحد خدمك في المطار قلت والله محترف
واحد في الشارع ويوقفك هذا اللي فعلا
بياثرك واقدر اقول لك قصص كثيره شركات
رؤساء شركات يعني دعيناهم
يزوروا المملكه سياحيه في بعضهم اذكر وحده
من رؤساء الشركات امريكيه
تعنى بالشريحه يمكن الدخل المرتفع مقرها
نيويورك رفضت انها تقابلني اول طلب وبعدين
شافتني التقيت فيها بمعرض وسمعتها اتكلم
وبعدين زارت معرض لزملائي كانوا مشاركين
فيه في امريكا المهم قررت تجي
بس قالت ما ابغى احد من استيري من هيئه
السعوديه للسياحه يشوفني ولا يعرف عن جدول
زيارتي
قعدت سته ايام قالت بدون ما نعرف وش سوت
بعدين كلمت الشخص اللي يعني الموظف اللي
معني بالسوق الامريكي قالت اذا اقدر
اقابلك انا باقي لي يومين بسافر اذا انت
موجود قبل
جلست تتعشى معاه
وقالت له لن اغفر لنفسي انا شفت من الناس
ما لازم اخبر به الناس اللي هناك
فالامثله كثير
وما دام اتكلم احنا على موضوع
يعني الارقام واللي تحقق والسياحه داخل
في انطباع ولا اظن انطباع اظن حقيقه انه
السياحه السعوديه او وجهات السياحيه
السعوديه هي للطبقه الثريه ما هي بالطبقه
المتوسطه الطبقه المتوسطه جدا منزعجه من
عدم توفر خيارات لهم في في تجاهل واضح انت
تلاقي العلا
فيه
استهداف لشريحه معينه السوده الان نسمع
نوعيه المشاريع اللي فيها ايضا تستهدف
شريحه معينه مشروع البحر الاحمر واضح من
مستوى التنفيذ الحالي قاعد يستهدف مين
فالشريحه اليوم المتوسطه ترى بانها غير
مستهدفه في السياحه
الداخليه وصار عنده خيارات ارخص واريح
بكثير في تركيا في مصر في دبي
وبدينا نشوف بعد ما كان فيه حماس للسياحه
الداخليه بدا ينخفض الحماس هذا بدانا نشوف
عوده اكتظاظ الوجهات الاقليميه اللي يمكن
ما حنقدر نافسهم بالاسعار ايش رايك ثلاث
نقاط النقطه الاولى تحفظ رقم ثلاثه انا
فعلا
احب رقم ثلاثه اول شيء في ارتفاع في
الاسعار غير مبرر
غير مبرر وفي عندك عرض وطلب كل مكان
العرض اقل من الطلب ترتفع الاسعار وتشوف
في الصيف الاسعار في الرياض نازله
والاسعار في عسير مرتفعه
الفاليو القيمه يعني مستوى الخدمه لا يعني
تتناسب مع الاسعار لكن هذا عرض وطلب وكل
مزاد كل ما زاد العرض كل ما يعني زادت
المنافسه وبالتالي الاسعار حتى تتوازن
نصيحتي للسياح
احجزوا بدري ان كان طيران تلقى الحين ثلث
السعر اللي بتدفعه لو تستنى الشتاء وتقرر
تروح الرياض عشان موسم الرياض الثلث وانا
مسؤول عن كلامي انا في مجلس اداره الخطوط
السعوديه واعرف
احجز الغرف في عسير احنا رحنا بزياره
تفقديه قعدنا في فندق الغرفه ب 600 ريال
خمس نجوم نفس الفندق الان واحنا نتكلم
واحنا نسجل بالفوميه ندلي الضعف 80% زياده
احجزوا بدري
فيه ارتفاع في الاسعار مبرر احنا قاعدين
نبني يعني وجهات
وتجارب نوعيه لان احنا بنبحث عن السائح
النوعي ما احنا بنبحث عن نحن زي ما قلت لك
النجاح الاقتصادي انه يكون عندك الانفاق
في المملكه فلا بد انك انت ترفع الجوده
بما يستقطب ويستهوي هذه الشرائح الابرز
الان هل هذا النقطه الثالثه هل هذا معناته
انه ما نطور شيء جديد للمتوسط الدخل الا
والقادم والاتي باذن الله في شركات تعمل
عليها يعني جهات كانت الوزاره وصندوق
التنميه السياحي وصندوق الاستثمارات
العامه في شركات الان تعمل على تطوير
وجهات
وتجارب وفنادق لشريحه شريحه متوسطه الدخل
بحيث انت تعطي فرصه للجميع
الاستمتاع بها ثروات الطبيعيه ان كان بحر
ولا ان كان جبل ولا ان كان صحيح فانت
مقتنعين الاسعار الحاليه غير منطقيه ولا
تناسب الخدمه المقدمه وتعملون على ايجاد
هذه البدائل جدا
وتفتيش يعني وزاره السياحه ترى كان وزاره
الصحه نتكلم عن مشرع بس نظام السياحه توه
معتمد مؤخرا واللي يعطيها الصلاحيه انها
فعلا تلزم الجهات الى درجه الاقفال مش بس
مخالفات الى جذره الاقفال اذا ما التزمت
بالمعايير والمواصفات اللي رخصت بناء
عليها في كلام كثير على الموضوع المشاهير
علاقتكم بالمؤثرين يمكن القصه الابرز
موضوع السفير السياحه
ميسي السفير السياحه يعيش عندنا وفي
كريستيانو رونالدو وفيه مغنيين في ممثلين
جو العلا
اشرح لنا وش فلسفتكم في استقطاب هالشخصيات
نجوم العالميين وهل يعني العائد يساوي
اللي قاعد نصرف عليهم
يعني انت ذكرت مشاهير
ويمكن تطرقت للاعب كوره
يعني مشهور يروج للسياحه
اخذ مسير ابتداء
اعرف الموضوع يعني قاهر ناس كثير بس احنا
لما بدينا معاه لكن ما كنا ننظر لك
كشخص
مشهور محبوب يتابعه على انستجرام اكثر من
400 مليون سائح
الانطباع الذهني عند الناس اذا قال هذا
المشهور هذه بلا تستحق الزياره
اكيد حيبدا ينبني والترغيب يبدا ينبني
وتقدر تقيس بعدد الناس لما يطلع يطلع
تغريده كم الناس اللي يتفاعلوا معاه وكم
ناس جوله الموقع فهل هذا اثر
يعني
اثر واضح يقاس والعائد المادي او العائدود
المادي يوازي اقول لك اكيد كم بس فتاه
وانا قدامك ما شاء الله تجيب المعلومات
بتجيب المعلوم تتاكد منك فعلا فتاه مع عرض
عليه كلام الحين ليش اختار يروح يلعب في
انتر ميلان يعني انا اقدر اقول لك
عفوا
اقدر اقول لك اللي قال لنا اياه حقه يقول
لما دخلت ابل ودخلت اديداس الرجال بيتقاعد
ما بقى له شيء هذول الشركات عقودها حتترك
ارث يعني لما بعد ما هو كلاعب وان هذا
بالنسبه لاهم بكثير من مجرد يلعب سنتين في
اي بلد كانت
بس هذا يعني اللعيبه ما ندخل في تعاقد
معهم ولا المفاوضات وقد يكون هذا يعني
فرصه اني اصحح بعض الاعتقاد الساده الناس
تشوف والله اعلن عن رونالدو
احنا زي ما قلت لك احنا نستفيد ونستغل كل
محتوى يطلع من اي جهه فاذا كان هذا
المحتوى حققته او هذا التعاقد نجاح حققته
مثلا وزاره الرياضه اكيد حنشتغل معهم
ونحاول ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تستفيد منه فيما يخص المشاهير
المعروفين اليوم بدينا ننظر للمشاهير
بتخصصات ما ندور بس مين اللي عنده اكبر
رقم لانه فيه اوفر في في تطابق بين
المتابعين لهذا المؤثر وهذا المؤثر فنجي
نشوف لكل بلد نبغى نشوف المؤثر هذا حيروج
لاي شريحه من اي بلد على اي خطوط الى اي
وجهات
فبدينا ندخل في تفصيل وعندنا صراحه 300
مؤثر نراقبهم ناس في حيجدبون الناس اللي
مهتمين بالتراث الثقافه وناس المهتمين
بالفعاليات ان كانت موسيقى ولا ان كانت
ايا كان ولا ازياء ايا كان
نجي بعدين المؤثرين اللي ما يمكن ما تعرف
انه مؤثرين لانك ما تشوفون في الاعلام بس
مهمين بالنسبه لنا رجع الاعمال
احنا استقطبنا اكثر من الف
شخص يشتغلوا في قطاع السياحه ومؤثرين على
مستوى الاعمال والراي هذول ما يحبوا
يعلنوا عن شغلهم واحنا عارفين بس اثرهم في
صناعه القرار صناعه القرار اللي تنعكس على
سلاسل الامداد
يمكن الاهم والابرز ترى اي بلد جديد
لما تروح بلد اول مره تسمع عنه ما حتقرر
تحت
تروح الوكاله سفر تنصح روح ولا ما اروح
هو وكانت سافروا السياحه اذا قالت ما
اعرفهم انزل مو مستحيل تروح انا قد سمعت
الحين عندي اتنام يقولولي رائعه ما شاء
الله حتى اني ما ادري لكن لو يجيني واحد
يشتغل في ترافل ولا واحد موظف يشتغل كانت
سفر يقول ترى كل اللي ارسلتهم
ارجعوا منبهرين واللي ارسلت لهم قعدوا في
كذا وكذا وفي خدم فبالتالي انا بهذا الشخص
اللي ينصح السائح اللي يخليه يتخطى
هالعقبات الذهنيه انه هذا بلد جديد ما
ادري كيف مستوى الخدمه ما ادري كيف
يعني الثقافه هل تقبلوني حيرحبوا فيني ام
لا
هدول جبنا منهم اكثر من الف مختص وناصح في
هذا القطاع في سلاسل الامداد وبالنسبه
للنعم نسوي عليهم نعطيهم حوافز بعد ما
يرجعوا ونعطيهم منصه اسمها خبير السعوديه
ندربهم وش تنصح فيه وش توري الناس واي صور
وبعدين نسوي عليهم تفتيش نروح لمواقعهم او
نروح للمواقع مقر المكاتب
سائح خفي ونشوف هل ينصحون بالسعوديه ولا
بيقول لك لا لا
وهذا شغالين عليها
احنا نحاسب
الشركائنا على الاداء وعلى القرايفلز
الاداء المتفقين عليه هل تنصح ام لا وعدد
الارقام الوصول هل بيجدون عقد ميسي كسفير
للسياحه السعوديه وش رايك
هل تنصح في العقد انتهى الموضوع انا اعتقد
الان عند جماهيريه عاليه في امريكا فهو لو
يقول للناس
للسوق الامريكي اليوم يقول روحوا للسعوديه
وهو يجي يعني انا مثلا جلست مع ميسي
وزوجته قالت انا باجي انا باجي الناس بس
يعني هجموها مسكينه
ترى هي انا اعتقد ما ابغى اجزم اعتقد انها
صديقاتها للسعوديه للسياحه بدون زواجها
وبدون عقد بدون ما يدفع لهم ولا ريال
معقوله معقولتين هذا عقد انه لا تقولون
هذا عقد
تدخل في النوايا شو اسوي لك بس لا صدقا
والله انا قاعد
ميسي يعني اتوقع انه حيطلع يتكلم لابد انه
يطلع يتكلم عن السعوديه لانه حقيقه مقتنع
ان السعوديه
تستحق الزياره وان الانطباع السائد غير
صحيح البته وعلى فكره ترى ما اعتقد واحد
زي ميسي تفرق معاه الفتات اللي انا ذكرت
لو ما هو مقتنع هو جاء وزار كان زيارتين
قبل ما يوقع العقد وقال لنا وش تبون اقول
لاني ماني قايل شيء انا ماني مقتنع فيه
عندك رونالدو رونالدو يقدر يتكلم عن
المملكه مسوي اعلان في دبي
قصدك بنزيما
اللي قالوا لك اللي حضرتك بنزيما
يعني كل مرحله عندك قوه وميز نسبيه لازم
تستفيد منها وحينستفيد من كل محتوى نروج
له واللي كنا مرتكزين عليه فطلع نرتكز
عليه لان ارتكز على ما هو اقوى واجمل
لو انا رائد اعمال وقاعد اسمع الحلقه هذه
واسمع عن مرحله يعني
يعني تاريخيا مقبل عليها السعوديه في فتح
السياحه انتوا الظالمين الى 2022 يسمون
اكتشف السعوديه
من 23 الى 2030 انتم مسمينها استمتع
بالسعوديه فهي المرحله الاهم اللي فيها
المنتجعات العملاقه
25 25 انا كرائد اعمال وين الفرس وين
تنصحني
اقول لك رسالتي لكل رواد الاعمال اذا عندك
شك ان الخدمه اللي ممكن تقدمها في مجال
السياحه يكون لها طلب ولا لا اقول لك ايه
والوجه اللي تروح لها صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه عفوا صندوق التنميه السياحي بدا
الصندوق
بالمشاريع الكبيره والنوعيه
اللي نسميها اليوم بدينا نشوف انه
الفرص النوعيه قد تاتي من الشركات الصغيره
وسووا صندوق خاص بالشركات الصغيره
المتوسطه ورواد الاعمال
وعندنا امثله كثيره احنا في الهيئه
السعوديه للسياحه حاولنا نوصل لرواد
الاعمال وطلعنا برنامج مع قناه الام بي سي
سميناه كرام
طلع من البرنامج التلفزيوني طلبات كثير
جتنا بالالاف منها
منصه حيهم هذه منصه حيهم او بالانجليزي
هاي
هاي هوم
كلها تجارب
سعوديه اصيله وعليها نمو كل سنه دعمنا
مثلا
احد القصص الناجحه الرائعه قادرين السكن
التشاركي وكل صيف نرفع معدل السكن
بالتعاون معهم ومعدلات الطلب عليها كبيره
فان كان في التقنيه
والخدمات المبيعات عفوا الصرف الترجمه
التسويق منصات اذا كنت بتسوي سوفت ويرز
للمبيعات كل الخدمات التي تخدم القطاع
السيك ابى اقول لك اقطع شك باليقين وروح
للصندوق وغالبا
حيدرسوا معاك دراسه الجدوى
تمويلك يقولون عشرين قانون عشرين ثمانين
صحيح مين هي العشرين في المئه من الدول
اللي بتجيب لنا 80% من السياح مركزين على
مين انتم
طبعا كل غرض العشرين ثمانين تختلف بس انا
اتكلم انت تسالني عن يعني مثلا العمره حتى
ظل الدول الاسلاميه هي اللي بتقدم لك اكبر
الاعداد مهما زاد العدد من مثلا بلد مثل
اوروبا بلجيكا
حتى لو كانوا اثرياء لن يغطوا الملايين
اللي يجوك من اندونيسيا
الكلام على
السياحه اقدر اقول لك انه
انت تنظر لي
ايش اللي عندك معروف انا لو عندي مثلا
سياحه التسوق هي الرائده ابغى اقول لك انه
الشرائح اللي حتيجي حتكون من مثلا الصين
هم اكبر المتسوقين في العالم اللي يروحون
يصرفون في التسوق احنا لو شفت الوجهات
اللي حين قاعدين نطورها ان كانت ثقافه او
ان كانت وجهات بحريه اتوقع
السياحه البحريه
والشواطئ حتكون هي الجاذب الاكبر ومين
اللي بيجيك وبيصرف مين 20
عندهم يخوت اللي عندهم قوارب اللي يشتغلوا
اللي يشتروا بيوت ثانويه ان كان البيوت
الثانويه هذولا في مكه والمدينه ولا ان
كان بيوت السنويه في عسير فممكن مصيف ولا
كان بيوت بيوت عائمه اللي يثبتوا اليخوت
عندنا على الوجهات البحريه فما اقدر اقول
لك والله هي دوله هي شرائح في كلها الدول
فقط على الغرب
ثلاث خطوط حنبدا نشغلها من الصين قريبا
حنععلن ان شاء الله في الصين
والحمله الاعلانيه اللي حتواكب الاطلاق او
الاعلان الرسمي للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
كوجهه تنصح تنصح بها الحكومه الصينيه
حتصاحب حمله اعلاميه ضخمه شوف اللي معاه
الوزير جوله عفوا ترى حتى في الهند فتحنا
مكاتب مع وزاره الخارجيه وشركه
الشركه المشغله
لتاشير فتحنا مكاتب كثير لتسهيل الحصول
على التاشيرات ان شاء الله الان احنا
ننتقل الى المنصه الالكترونيه
كازاخستان يعني صار عندنا خطوط مباشره
مخطط لها من خلال قاعدين نركز على كل رحت
للاندونيسيا رحت لكل هذه الدول اللي انا
ذكرت لك اياها واشوف انا الجوله اللي معاي
الوزير السياحه في الخليج وتوقيع اتفاقيه
التاشيره السياحيه الموحده اظن انه
بالنسبه في امريكا اللاتينيه ولا امريكا
ولا الصين زينا احنا لما نروح اوروبا ما
نبرض او روح اليابان ولا يتضارب مشوار على
دوله واحده ولا مكان واحد يعني غالبا ابغى
اخذ لي تمشيه في البقعه هذه
لو تسولفنا على موضوع التاشيره الموحده
وايش فكرتها وين قاعدين نوصل فيها هذا
مسار تعمل عليه وزاره السياحه لكن الوزير
كان يعني جمعنا ويقول استفدنا من تجربه
قطر في كاس العالم
بسبب التسهيل هذا ليش ما نبدا حتى المهم
لازم مع كل الدول نبدا مع دوله يعني دوله
بعد الاخرى يمكن
اللي اعلن عن اللي ذكرته كانت وزيره
السياحه البحرينيه بعد ما التقت بوزير
السياحه السعودي وكذلك عمان بعد ولا لا
انا اللي اعلم عنه عن هذا لانه كنت في
الاجتماع ونحن نبحث كيف ان احنا ن كررها
التجربه ونبدا نعممها بس ما بعده اعلن عن
اي شيء الى الان سؤال قبل الاخير تفضل في
رحله السائح او الزائر اللي من برا
وين كانت اكثر نقطه
منخفضه في الرضا
مع الجهات
متى لانه هذا متغير اقرب اخر رصد اخر رصد
وش كانت النقطه الادنى في رضا السائح
الزحام حتى هذا وصل لهم
لانه
يجي ويقضي ثلاث ارباع او يعني نقول مثلا
ساعه ساعتين قاعدين ينتقل من مكان لمكان
المفروض ينتقل له في خلال ربع ساعه او ثلث
ساعه
الرياض اليوم اصبحت من اهم الوجهات
السياحيه اللي ما فيها من يعني فعاليات
واعمال وحتى
الدرعيه
المصمك المتاحف كل شيء
حافه العالم فالرياض
انا وانت عايشين فيها ونعرف مشاكل الزحام
العسير في الصيف كانت اهم مشكله الزحام بس
ترى يعني ما ابغى اقول يعني لا يتفرد من
سالتني عن الاعلى
انت اول رئيس للهيئه السعوديه للسياحه
كل القاده كل قاده هذا القطاع هم مؤسسين
لمرحله
تاريخيه في السعوديه لقطاع جديد قاعد يبدا
ويطلق قدراته يوم ما حتغادر زي اي مسؤول
يعني
يمكن ترى يقولون دائما يقابلون
بعدها الله يستر عليك الله يسلمك شكرا او
يترقون
يوما ما
ايش اكثر شيء حتكون فخور فيه سواء تحقق او
تتمنى تحققه لما تغادر هذا الكرسي
اللي اتمناه واعمل جاهدا من اجله اني ابني
قيادات
لهذا الوطن اينما حلوا
ومحترفين صناعه السياحه والاحترافيه تاتي
بعمل مؤسسه
بقياس اداه
بالتزام باهداف ومحاسبه
المسؤولين اما
بانجازات
ونشكرهم
ونثني على مقام به واذا كان جهد ولم يحقق
المامول
نستفيد من كل الدروس المستفاده اليوم انا
فخور فعلا
الفريق اللي حولي واستطاع انه يخليني
اتحدث نيابه عنهم صدق والله ترى مجامله
عندي فريق رائع احنا اليوم قربنا 600 موظف
عندنا
ناس تتكلم 26 لغه عالميين فكره احترافيا
ولا زلنا جدد على على القطاع فبالتالي
وحيكون في طلب عليهم كبير انا اذا عفيت
انا اتمنى انهم هم يستقطبوا لقيادات في
هذا القطاع موفقين ان شاء الله
ونتطلع للعشره في المئه ولا تج محلي لاكثر
من 100 مليون زائر حنشوف تارجت الجديد
حقكم
ول3 مليون وظيفه تخلق ان شاء الله تعالى
بحلول عشرين ثلاثين شكرا شكرا لك يا ابو
شكرا لكم شكرا في هذا القصير في اعداد
وانتاج الحلقه ياسر الغانم في اداره
التصوير وفي التصوير عبد الرحمن عبود
مسؤول الاضاءه غالب جنودي ياسر كدشه مساعد
اضاءه وفي تسجيل الصوت والهندسه الصوتيه
عبد العزيز المزي وفي التحرير انس الخليل
وفي الاشراف على انتاج غيداء التميمي
واصيل بافرد هذا بودكاست سقراط احد منتجات
شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]